bajo concentrados y armados el escuadrón
especial de vigilancia e intervención se
prepara para la misión del día estos
hombres forman parte de un ejército
verde de 650 soldados que se ha
desplegado por todo el país hombres
entrenados para luchar pero también
especializados en agroforestería según
el comandante diarra la creación del
escuadrón en 2018 surgió de ver la gran
deforestación
en algún momento el gobierno se dio
cuenta de que la deforestación estaba
alcanzando nuevos picos desde la
independencia hasta ahora costa de
marfil ha perdido el 70% de sus bosques
consecuencia de la actividad humana
desde la tala ilegal y la extracción de
oro hasta el cultivo clandestino de
cacao
así es la vigilancia tenemos que
movernos todo el tiempo ser ágiles y
estar al tanto de todo manteniendo un
ojo en el suelo y también por encima de
él el escuadrón utiliza drones que
pueden cubrir grandes superficies de
tierra y detectar actividades ilegales
fuera se crean campamentos en estos
bosques protegidos no podemos
detectarlos desde el suelo pero gracias
al throne podemos verlos y acceder a
ellos y se politice invisibles
en un bosque cercano donde no se permite
la tala la brigada acaba de descubrir un
montón de madera en cuestión de minutos
pueden ver a unos sospechosos
después de una persecución de media hora
y los soldados arrestan a tres jóvenes
pero después de interrogarlos la unidad
se ve obligada a dejarlos ir por falta
de pruebas tangibles
lamentablemente los hombres que
capturamos no son los responsables pero
nunca abandonarán a sus amigos
por eso les dio un consejo y trate de
hacerles entender que nuestra acción es
lo mejor para todos que lo que hacemos
es por nuestros hijos por nuestro futuro
más allá de la vigilancia educar a las
comunidades rurales sobre el ecosistema
del bosque y su fragilidad es una de las
misiones centrales del escuadrón
la agricultura en costa de márfil sigue
siendo responsable el 60 por ciento de
la destrucción de los bosques